zickig als rüstung alter ich bin
komplett mx gold mit der goldkette mit
dessen airbag des todes somit den
hipster jolo hosen angezogen den crash
in dieser runde alles einfach nur
prinzip hole ich mir zum goldwert
ladies and gentlemen aloha schmal und
herzlich willkommen zu einer runde neuen
seiner runde neun
jetzt bin ich auch schon total verstellt
und das passt total zufolge hier
challenge accepted wo vielleicht hätte
das noch gar nicht und zwar schreibt
könnt ihr jetzt in die kommentare
schreiben was ich beim nächsten mal so
machen soll wie zum beispiel tastatur
verstellen oder irgendwie sowas die
serial total lange nicht mehr gekommen
jedenfalls habe ich diesmal die
challenge dass ich mir ein paar sachen
umgestellt zum beispiel wfw es auf d und
b auf es heißt wenn ich jetzt zb drücke
laufe ich nach links
die drücke lauf nach hinten drücken
laufen nach vorne und es nach rechts
also ich muss eigentlich a doppel ist
sprinten
wie ist links es ist rechts und ja ich
hoffe dass sie zu oft
okay das ist dass es links okay gut und
jetzt muss ich halt schaffen so lange
wie möglich zu überleben das heißt sie
wird wahrscheinlich sehr defensiv
spielen schreibt mir die kommentare wenn
ihr mehr wollt und gibt auf jeden fall
so viele daumen hoch wie es geht dafür
dass ich das hier ausprobieren
die jungs klar gedrückt halten oh mein
gott walther das ist so komisch das ist
echt sofa kalter man denkt echt einfach
dass man mit dass man mit je schneller
läuft weil das halt sonst auch mal so
ist wenn ich jetzt direkt getötet werde
ich schwöre euch ich klatsche die so
also ehrlich accepted es immer dass ich
halt zu zehn minuten damit spielen muss
nicht einfach so dass wenn ich tot bin
das dann hier vorbei ist jungen also
wenn man sich etwa daran gewöhnt dass
ich richtig ich habe angst dass ich mich
jetzt die ganze zeit an diesem scheiß
hier gewöhnen jemand hinter mir
jaha oft hinter mir her ihr penner
nein nein frieden frieden junge junge
junge frieden frieden frieden frieden
bringen ja ich habe ein team partner ja
ich liebe dich ja teampartner ist in der
aufnahme mein held war das heißt ihr
habt mir vielleicht ein bisschen längere
runde sollte man die tomate ein bisschen
lauter okay die hinten nach vorne
der junge so schuh anziehen so wohin so
ist es gut dass ich jetzt ein team
partner alter das ist immer gut
bescheinigt accepted alter so ich laufe
einfach vor der fischkopf ich werden
solche folgen
ja ja also mir folgen weil sie jetzt
richtig kennen die märkte nicht aber es
entscheidet die kann man erstmal
abschlachten und kühe dass auf jeden
fall erstmal erfahrung da oben auch also
technisch accepted wenn ihr das noch
nicht kennt und das kennen
wahrscheinlich sehr viele noch nicht
weil die letzten folgen halt sehr sehr
alt sind bzw noch kein halbes jahr her
sind würde ich sagen untereinander nein
jetzt ist das besonders gut mit der
steuerung
scheiße alter [ __ ] und man hätte ich
eine richtige steuerung bringt es
bestimmt besser gewesen egal jungs
hängen oft hinten dran so leute nächste
runde startet in 20 sekunden immer noch
gleiche tastenbelegung a nach vorne
laufen wie nach links nach rechts und
den nach hinten das ist so komisch am
liebsten würde ich mal ganz christi fest
kann darauf richten allerdings geht die
109 sekunden direkt schon los konkreter
du geile sau jugend jetzt geht's ab
lernspiel bay ich laufe nicht in die
mitte da bekomme ich eine sache nicht
auf direkt hier rein so scheiße läuft
auch hinterhalt ich hoffe das ist kein
engländer so und er tötet mich jetzt
nicht direkt sondern ich habe vorhin
gesagt bitte nicht direkt töten
schlag mich halt unnötig ja geil schuhe
wie unnötig bitte was ist das für ein
penner
was sollen so was warum macht man sowas
junge wie behindert was ist was soll
denn so was
chillig alter geil das sind penner man
so leute nächste runde beginnt in 15
sekunden und ich starrte ihn neben dem
blog das hatte ich auch noch nicht also
sehr komisch fünf sekunden vier sekunden
drei sekunden zum sieg und ich hoffe
jetzt bleibe ich länger und wird nicht
mehr angeschlagen vor allem okay ich
konnte ich sprinter am anfang schuldig
vor allem auch sehr witzig der typ der
mich getötet hat hat mich mit der hand
getötet und er hieß master of survival
games oder irgendwie so also wenn er das
als master definiert okay das wäre wohl
eher ein abgebrochener bachelor online
ich hoffe ich mache dich nachher wieder
so eine wiederholung daran
naja jedenfalls habe ich hier einen weg
mehr oder weniger und zwar muss ich
erstmal agenten in den pflege
traumverein kommen und das ist mit der
steuerung so verdammt schwierig ja da
hinten schon die erste kiste die hier
wartet man zwei schwerter so dass er
schon mal gut so es müsste dahin noch
eine kiste seinen der anderen ecke der
anderen also es ist echt soko so
schwierig denn wenn ihr hier
wenn irgendeiner jr dreistein schwert
halter läuft nämlich wenn irgendjemand
ja meckern ist und mal so
luca des voll schlecht day du bist voll
behindert was stellst dich an
man ist einfach daran gewöhnt dass man
via sd so dass man da so vernünftig
halte mitlaufen kann wisst ihr
weil und und die zum beispiel sind
direkt nebeneinander das heißt für zwei
verschiedene finger
das heißt man hat gleichzeitig immer so
links und rechts zu abschätzen kann so
relativ genau
allerdings ist das bei mir jetzt hast du
zeit du spielst alter damit ich jetzt
noch mal punkte landen kann
bei mir ist zurzeit allerdings so hält
das world wide web entstehen du musst du
musst einfach sterben ich muss jetzt
einfach mal enthüllt mit dieser komische
steuerung bei mir ist halt so dass ich
lenken aufdeckt auf dem gleichen finger
bezug mittelfinger prologis weg verfolgt
den anderen durch
ich hab grad nicht so das
selbstbewusstsein nicht irgend etwas
reißen zu wollen müssen tun handeln sein
wird so bock 3 ich kann doch hier einen
links hoch klettern nochmals skill eine
kein spiel so sehen wir hier über und er
ist gestorben
sodann apfel können wir ein bisschen
über die bäume klettern so das hat uns
unglaublich viel gebracht leute das war
somit das stimmt das hab ich in der
letzten aufnahme die ich hier gemacht
haben beziehungsweise runde die ich hier
gespielt habe auch gemacht und es war so
mega unnötig aber danach bin ich bei den
zaun gelaufen das hab ich jetzt gar
nicht gemacht
naja wenn es auch nicht gemacht hat
schreibt irgendwas in die kommentare was
ich eventuell auch noch machen soll halt
habe ich die kisten da oben schon
eingesammelt was ich ihre girl was sich
eventuell auch noch machen sondern
ständig accepted also das ist echt an
wen kann ich euch empfehlen werden als
erstes nicht in mitte läuft sondern zu
diesem park hin dass ich vier fünf
kisten und ihr seht ich hab jetzt was
keine rüstung selber zu fall aber ich
habe kein stein schwer tun alles
mögliche
den rest des weges mache ich gerade
alles nur zufällig dabei ist jetzt
gerade nicht also das ist halt so der
anfang vom weg habe ich auch noch zwei
kisten die sind allerdings schon leer
alter hier das ist auch gut also dieser
diesem app hat allgemein sehr viele
kisten ich glaub auch das wasser auf
dieser map ist giftig glaube ich
berichte ich mich wenn es falsch ist ein
letztes wasser rein gegangen und war
fast tot
hier komme ich nicht sonst würde ich
sagen dass ich mal eben hier drauf
laufen dann hinten auf die dächer
daraufhin auf den dächern
wenn man relativ guten ausblick so ohne
falsche taste was auch rückwärts das war
rückwärts
also so und so war das ist echt komisch
nicht aufwendig an geradeaus und nur mit
dem aus ich mache kein bisschen die
irgendwie mit rechts links laufen oder
so weil das auch fast gar nicht geht
also es ist echt komisch ich würde jetzt
gern sagen ja ihr könnt mir video
antworten senden wenn ihr rucksack wenn
ihr meint dass ihr das besser könnte
aber es gibt hier keine video antworten
wir das voll doof so hier gehe ich mal
die tür ist offen
da war schon jeder beinahe jeder ich
hoffe halt einfach nur dass mich kein
irgendwie von hinten angreifen da müsste
ich mich ganz schnell umdrehen und im
zweikampf ist man ja immer ein bisschen
weniger wenn man dann so wenn man so
nach links läuft dann so nach rechts wo
ich halt zur zeit warten jetzt laufen
erst richtig halte ich bin wenigstens
stück scheiße was es gibt auf der welt
und ich brauchen ofen
da bräuchte wie komme ich denn jetzt so
komme ich da hoch
lecker schnitt so ich habe 2 ich könnte
mir theoretisch noch gold wert kräften
aber so bringt mir das nichts passieren
kann ich jetzt alles einfach hier mit
alter alles mit nur froh dass name so du
wirst gewusst
keller der wird gebremst und bis sein
name ok wollen wir junge macht oder
wollen wir abdecken was es einer ist der
sarg von jolo machen wollen wir jolo
machen ich meine ich hab die steuerung
stoffen gekehrt wollen allerdings machen
alter wie sogar ständig an wert eine
viel bessere rüstung da macht seinen
gold auch nichts aus junge alte und
jetzt lektor dass hier die bank den
brand im duett stehen älter ich werde
jetzt runtergelaufen käme und mich
geboxt hätte alter dann wäre dann wäre
es gewesen mit mir
aber ich kann auch nicht mehr richtig
laufen mit dieser scheiße hier
das ist echt kacke dass es einfach nur
ein defizit mehr oder weniger es ist
echt einfach nur defizitären würdest du
sagen holzblock ich auch noch wo ich
blocke nicht mehr umgestellt hat und
alles auch man bindung des todes nun
bleibt bestehen oder töte mich oder so
der ist viel besser ausgerüstet
plötzlich vista software hier rum
hier kann man aber auch gut weg laufen
jetzt ist aber auch gut möglich
ich glaube das geht einfach bis zum
deathmatch oder bisher nicht mehr
sprinten kann und wahrscheinlich volles
leben
ach man toll verfolgungsjagd hier mitten
in janecek selb denn eigentlich sollte
ich verfolgt dass ich immer so bei
dieser serie a jugend dass er sich auch
gar nicht um dreht also ich weiß nicht
vielleicht läuft auch mit der 5 ach man
hier noch hinterher komme ich nehme
jetzt erstmal sehr unnötig so jetzt
freuen sich erst mal der kartoffel aber
immer mit der ruhe jungs denn der hätte
hätte ich schon längst töten können
einfach
schiene zu erstellen städte ich hab
einfach mal 55 stein später ist es so
heftig ich habe fünf stein schwerte
allein diese tatsache dass fünf
streichwert ab jetzt habe ich sogar noch
schüchtern aber ich hab nur noch eine
hose dann habe ich halt noch bis zum
mehr oder weniger also ich sags euch
diese map ist so unfassbar bestückt mit
kisten das ist heftig und es auch noch
eine ist mittlerweile so echt fast zu
meinen lieblings map ich hatte euch
jetzt grad zeigen kann das wasser giftig
ist aber ich bin echt froh wenn ich hier
keinen schaden nehme scheiß alter der
viel besseres tun hat sich ja dann
verläuft der luft den anderen da hier
das ist meine chance wenn die jetzt im
kampf sind dann habe ich die einfach
beide putztrupps okay jetzt bin ich
wollte ich bin tot auf walter nein
verdammt delta ich denke auch eine runde
dran okay leute herzlich willkommen in
der 13 vierten runde sogar vornehmlich
durch auch gesagt zwei tages war die
dritte und es geht direkt los so hat
dieser tollen web wo ich vorhin einfach
so getötet wurde ich hoffe das passiert
nicht wenn es nicht passiert dann hänge
ich keine mehr dran als ihr könnt quasi
nur hoffen dass es nicht passiert naja
ich hab nix das verstehe nicht wenn die
ersten leute schon box warum warum könnt
ihr nicht abwarten halten diese punkte
geilen immer so ich hoffe mir läuft
diesmal kein alter her
und wenn dann kriegt jetzt schwert ins
gesicht so ich hab mir schwer das ist ja
schon mal was gut ist
wohin 15 stein schwerter da wird jetzt
froh wenn ich das von mir sagen könnte
aber egal man will ja nicht beschweren
und steinegg so so allem ein immer so
herumgespielt nimmt die andere route
nehmen die doch auch mal ich bin bei der
anderen route der deal auf mittlerweile
so viele dass ist mittlerweile keine um
gespielt route mehr das ist einfach eine
allgemeine gute und deswegen bleibe ich
einfach bei einer never change a running
system ist also bei mir läuft diese
route hier einmal so von items außer man
geht erhalten einfach so getötet
das natürlich doof so hier ist noch eine
kiste und stein schwer tat es gut durch
so scheint ganz cool zu werden ist
diesmal eine kiste und ich war leute
okay ist aber keiner so dingsbums jetzt
zum anziehen
eine flasche flasche whisky die buddel
voll rum so ich hoffe mal dass ich jetzt
diesmal auf welche umbringen kann
und dahinter eine explosion
wenn ich meine hier ist keiner
also ich kann auch nicht so gut weil
diese softbox blendet ein halt schon
heftig heftig deftig wird sich gut
porsche mit
okay okay
hier ist noch eine kiste tüchern ist das
besser nachkam egal
lauf ich halt in den in den goldenen rx
he rum sowie ist der kleine mann
ich werde einfach out prinzip auch mal
einen töten hier wirklich einfach nur
aus prinzip eine schwere goldene airmax
womit die goldenen airmax einfach mal
drin lassen von anderen der wenigen die
ihn jetzt habe ich die 4000er max bei
mir drin stehen die anderen halt kein
diese stört hier ist eine kiste einen
goldenen brustpanzer soweit wir mal
komplett golden hier das ist ja geil des
sportbunds
das ist links so dass es rechts und
hinten durch ähnlich sind bin ich echt
so selten gelaufenen ergänzt es unnötig
des todes so hier ist überhaupt nicht wo
spender belgier dann ist hier eine ich
glaube hier sind hilfen und soja
genommen so ein stark am ball nach einer
schönen punkte absahnen
so wie könne eventuell war unser
schwertern verzaubern mich so ein
bisschen erfahrung ins abgreifen
nur clever erfahrungen ja schlimme forum
wendet ist noch ein hühnchen so oft rot
sowie bauern ein bisschen sonst ich weiß
nicht soll ich da drauf rum stolz hier
noch der leiter her komm ich mache jetzt
einfach mal schauen ob die kiste während
noch volles wenn ich hoffe ich wieder
zurück und läuft dann in den wald oder
oder schlimm die kiste jetzt gerade
links im bild ist schnell leben dennoch
sieht 9 ist noch relativ viele die dies
noch voll da rauskam auf jeden fall
schon mal brötchen machen so jungs jolo
halbe rüstung kaputte gerade jungs sonst
lief auf jeden fall jetzt sitzen wir
hier soll über die bäume immer noch
bedenken ich hab diese perfekte
steuerung drin ich finde dafür meister
ich mich ja eigentlich ganz gut durch
ist nix lehnt bisher ist nichts los ist
nix löwen ist nichts drin
scheiße mann das ist so blöd da wo man
eigentlich so recht läuft man dann auf
einmal rüttgers wenn ich jetzt recht
laufen will und auch die rechts laufend
taste drücke springe ich quasi auf der
stelle
das ist verdammt ärgerlich lange ja
wissen was zu fressen wenigstens so dass
es sich doch erstmal aber sind hier auch
keine leute aber wahrscheinlich in die
kiste noch leer ist es tägliche oben
wahrscheinlich auch leer nachdem also
ein bisschen längere runde
ich weiß nicht über 20 minuten geht das
bestimmt und schreibt immer einfach ob
ihr mehr change accepted wollten weder
gibt am besten daumen hoch das sieht man
daran am besten sagen wir mal wenn ihr
5000 schafft an seite die besten jeder
in die allerbesten einfach ich liebe
euch dann kommen keine kids beweg dich
nach mensch gut formbar ist jetzt ein
bisschen auf gegner gegeben damit dass
ihr noch mal ein bisschen spannend werde
ich mein handy
kein getötet oder haben wir ein getötet
weil es nicht die kreise doch aber nicht
dass wir auf jeden fall schädlich wenn
jetzt noch so ein töten würden somit
sondern abgefuckt steuerung übrigens
verstehe ich das nicht alle sagen immer
öl pvp nut kontrakte wie kann man hier
etwas nötig seien immer nicht nehmen
halt nur nicht so die die besten runden
halt immer sonnig nehmen dies als erstes
aufnehmen und so was alles und ich weiß
nicht also ich gucke selber letzt player
die jetzt nicht so die ganz besten sind
wo ich einfach denke sie können gut
unterhalten
ein bisschen ich meine guckt euch
brocken fenster die sind jetzt auch
nicht so unglaublich gut oder eher wie
ein megaprojekt vor allem aber ich gucke
mir halt zum beispiel sind die einzigen
leute die ich mir angucke weil weiß
nicht ich stehe nicht so also skills
natürlich schon geil aber ich nehme mir
halt so auf unterhaltung das habe ich
auch eine mega party video gestern
gesagt hat mir der unterhaltung auf
jeden fall wehrt er wichtige faktoren
das angeht ferien und worauf gilt finde
ich gar nicht so ausschlaggebend
ich möchte gut unterhalten werden dann
im sport wenn er zum beispiel ein
fußballteam unglaublich schlecht war
also in der zehnten liga spielen würde
aber so witzig wäre immer so sicher
alles auf den arm nehmen würde und so
was alles dann wichtig zum beispiel
unglaublich hart feiern da hinten ist
gerade ein typ und wird mir die trotzdem
halt angucken
ich habe bogen junge immer nur so schuhe
als ich hab doch eine e mail
was wollen die denn in den goldenen r
max streif der hier drüber junge bei mir
sind schon jetzt einfach nur noch max
weiß doch was die räder sagen alter max
band los lust so hier ist die treppe gut
und böse studios so geht sie noch ein
hier geht's lang so lück werz und jetzt
springen cool jetzt bin ich hier was
mache ich jetzt auch fakt ist so toll
wir sind nicht kisten sind einfach
keinen wir sind einfach keine kisten
ich habe jetzt ist nur noch
zwei kisten ich öffne kisten nur noch
mit meinem männer mit meinen goldenen
airmax alter ich hoffe meine bringt
glück schreibt meine kommentare ob das
jetzt glück bringt oder nicht
okay da kann ich einfach hochklettern
kann ich nicht wir auch ein bisschen
locker wie sie meine suppe meinem stil
so ich muss auf jeden fall nach da oben
okay da ja toll wie soll ich das denn
jetzt machen
da komme ich da nicht hoch oder doch
kommt man so hier rum hier rum so wenn
da jetzt wenn die eine noch voll ist ist
die andere auch vorjahr man geil
okay ein bisschen was zu fressen ist gut
ich habe jeder noch so ein kleines an
der spitze kann ich auch mal eben junger
alter ich habe dieses netbook wollen wir
einfach aus prinzip die goldene
aufsetzen kommen jetzt werden die ganzen
pvp spieler wieder meint lr gibt es viel
bessere wahl
das sind 4 das sind der da kommt das ist
nicht mehr sehr viel besser das sind 4
und 4 deswegen wir setzen einfach aus
prinzip jetzt immer nur goldene sachen
opfer von meinem auf hunger games alter
der großen hunger der frist ein paar
tausend jahren im schnitzel ofcom noch
ein wir zwar nur eins aber kompliziert
er 22 minuten aber noch menschen oder 2
verwickelt hat egal jungen alter dmx
leiden bei uns an der pfeile
wir haben viele 04 ok ok dmx junge dmx
pistole ich bin komplett goldjungs fick
dich als rüstung alter ich bin komplett
r max goldt mit der goldkette mit dessen
airbag des todes mit den hipster jolo
hosen angezogen den crash in dieser
runde alles einfach aus prinzip hole ich
mir zum goldwert
ich habe gold wert jungs
so die brauche ich zum kisten öffnen
sodann dann trace ich mir erstmal hier
so ein ding hier kommt das was unnötiges
muss jetzt das ist unnötig bibel so
nötig 60 sekunden
ok warum es wirklich komplett in gold
machen sie machen das komplett in gold
alter wesen gold des todes das ist das
hippste gold auf einem foto das ist echt
geil
also ich wer sonst so so ok warte worauf
man letztlich kann ich mir ach so hat
die steuerung noch umgestellt
also ihr könnt ihr das nicht
kontrollieren dass ich hier so laufer
mittmann der steuerung obwohl könnte
theoretisch doch warte ich zeig doch mal
ganz kurz auf meine tastatur
da guck ich gebe hier aber ich laufe da
sieht man hier das a
ich hoffe vorwärts ich werde
abgeschossen alte ich werd abgeschossen
ich werde abgeschossen hätte dass man
nicht machen das war nur eine angel der
mit schubsen halte ich muss mich
irgendwie flash retten
ich muss einfach nur laufen ich muss
einfach nur laufen einfach nur laufen
junge welt ist ja dann zeige ich euch
einmal da zeige ich euch einmal ob das
stimmt und ich werde direkt
abgeschlossen
junge direkt schon wieder mehr sein maul
halten alter mann nur weil ich euch das
gezeigt haben
seht ihr das ist brutal roth rau frauen
ab auch maniche hätte es locker reifen
können so bisschen meinem einen goldenen
sache nämlich keiner bussen können
na gut muss man mit leben traurig alter
nur weil ich euch das jetzt so gut und
meine ganze basecamp sie wieder
verstellt nur weil ich euch das jetzt
mal zeigen wollte auch mal gut egal ihr
seht hier nochmal controls forward w
links zurück s und das b.to jetzt sind
wir normal
na gut leute wenn ihr mehr
celik accepted wollt dann gibt einen
daumen hoch und 5000 oder wird fällig
wenn ihr das schafft wenn ich hier
keinen zweck ihre hipster und wenn ihr
jetzt immer noch dran sein und ihr das
gerade seht was ich gerade sage live
dann erstmal euch und schreibt man bitte
alle goldene airbags in die kommentare
weil dann denken die anderen die nicht
so weit gekommen höhe beim schreiben
dieser silber voll dumm aber nicht alte
tier die coolen egal wie das beim
nächsten mal wieder kampf changes in die
kommentare schreiben